you see my gross feet well i guess
they're not that bad but i've often sat
here wondering what it'd be like to have
soft
smooth feet that i could rub my hands
over like it's a dove commercial
so when i came across these foot peeling
masks on tick tock i was like oh
tell me more so i've sent these foot
masks to myself and two friends to see
whether they work or not and to see
whether all that skin peeling is worth
it now be warned this is gonna peel my
skin off it's not gonna happen
immediately i'm gonna have to wait a few
days
but this is going to peel my skin off
viewer discretion is advised
[Music]
i have seen these on tick tock very
briefly
i hate gross tick-tock so if anything
shows up like that i just scroll past
really fast when we were young we used
to put like
glue on our hands then peel it off i
don't know why but
that's what this foot peel reminds me of
people joke about you know
charging for videos of their feet but
here i am doing it for free
definitely have some calluses right on
this part of my foot
don't know how they got there don't know
how to get rid of them i do have some
rough feet
so i'm really hoping that this works i'm
kind of scared to do this
wait what oh this feels weird
now i just have to let my feet marinate
[Music]
it feels like i'm in a kiddie pool full
of like oobleck or something
oh yeah i guess i'll check back in a
couple days when
anything starts happening see you later
i just played tennis and when i took my
socks off
skin started flaking out of my socks and
onto the ground
and i can see where my skin is starting
to peel that is my
skin stuck to my sock oh my god that's
so gross
my feet are doing something kind of
weird they're kind of shiny
and they feel really tight especially on
top of my feet the skin is really dry
and really shiny something's definitely
happening see that
oh they're so dried out oh yes
oh you know just minding my business in
public with my feet
shedding so the peeling actually
kind of peaked there and it never got a
full peel the back of the package says
that if you have tougher skin it may not
exfoliate as much
and then you can try a second
application so right now
i've got a second set on my feet and i'm
gonna give it another week
see how that does for me i just really
want my feet to peel okay
my calluses look worse than before i
feel like people are staring at my feet
i'm over this foot peel they look very
scary and i
i'm just hoping that it gets better okay
now we're starting to get some results
look at
that now that is the kind of peeling i
am looking for
it's not coming off in like one big
chunk but it's starting to like
flake and peel like a corpse
okay so it's been just about a week and
my feet
they're still peeling but they're pretty
smooth holy
feet look at that do you see that my
feet are
so soft now i can't stop touching them
it's past the number of days that the
peel said it needed to work
and my foot never fell off the peeling
that you see in those viral tic tocs
where the whole like exterior part of
your skin falls off to reveal like that
baby smooth skin underneath
that never happened to me there is some
peeling around parts of my foot that
were already kind of calloused
and gross and dead but i'm pretty
disappointed
that i didn't get baby butt soft
feet by the end of this thing so i'm
very sorry for anyone who's hoping to
see
my little foot carcass my feet are so
soft i
didn't think that my feet would ever
stop peeling and they're still peeling a
little bit my calluses were so rough and
cracked and dry and gross and they're so
like smooth and like it's this foot peel
is literally magic
go get it my feet are very soft they
feel very nice
and that peeling was very satisfying so
i'd recommend this to anyone
if you do this wear socks to bed it may
be uncomfortable but
otherwise you're gonna wake up with a
bunch of skin flakes in your bed and
you're gonna have to vacuum your sheets
in the morning which is not something
people normally need to do
have you ever peeled your feet like this
let us know in the comments down below
and a link to check out the mask we use
will be in the description thank you so
much for watching
and i will talk to you guys in the next
one bye-bye
i'm probably gonna end up on a foot
fetish website aren't i
you